just going to back off several pop are
they going to go
oh who didn't quite get to bang me my
wolf comes back with a headbutt
pulverized granny Kaiser comes out right
over training of the back lines with
Peggy with a big absolute zero Mar and
is huge literally because that wild
growth booty manages to catch faker with
his ultimate at Baker back you a fanatic
in big trouble double kill for Betty
ready make it triple kill and now
guys it wasn't too long ago that South
Korea was the odds-on favorite for just
about any international League of
Legends competition but after the 2018
World Championship I think it's safe to
say that perception has been shattered
you might even say the gap is finally
beginning to close hectically LPL got
three teams out of groups yep
else okay did not but forget about that
stuff guys cuz we're turning back the
clock to a time when Korea smashed any
foreigners it came across in League of
Legends Oh chilling smite sent torn in a
lot of trouble you're now this video
will be divided up into three roughly
historical time periods the modern era
the SKT dynasty and the og an era now
let's start this video off with a look
at the state of Korean dominance against
foreigners over the last two or three
years most of the leaders are coming
towards the mid lane there's the China
three with the earth beneath let's run
seven verses down one four zero those
shop I betrayed only on the support
event not going to make it much longer
as well the chase is it look at this
beautiful plays out of faker crushing
the back went by in the south applause
around smeb walks down to 4th the river
here and as he goes back into the lane
he realizes this is not a place he wants
to be n / the / hextech ultimatum hold
sit down Kati top laners and suddenly
tried to map kids first blood and a 1
versus 2 he's allowed to make it to Duke
we'll go in a resurrection but that is
the play for spare there's a thing about
a table pump is you give them freedom if
they're able to engage on to double if
you know if it isn't that clumped up by
then they just go in to take him down
potentially if I'm coming in here from
you tell this is that engaged you'll be
talking about ring of frost quickly on
Duke Smith you know lay its Mitte
trying to get the stun on Samad about
how he is locked up and taking down a
double kill Pratap mistake in the mid
lane a little bit over aggressive for
this target Katie make them pay
yep and that was just the thing of
beauty from Mata to completely change
the scope of the 4v4 yes Katie have been
destroyed
nice initiation from Katie scores gonna
make sure they've got themself the first
one but Nick coming in to turn the fight
back around
he'll disengage immediately recognizing
to be free is not in in the late game Oh
in the mid to late game plays items come
together he's in the epidural
ripped Harold in the middle of fanatics
space at 20 minutes Conn can cut through
these towers in an instant fnatic are
out of options they got one last chance
one opportunity to try to see the fight
but there is nothing in their wheelhouse
there is nothing in the toolkit all they
see as masses in front of them this game
is the story of con farming it up and
bringing it up saving the Drake bound
got to already Bank is hiding and coming
back looking to come in here comes your
shock wave Katie with a filter response
will take down
maybe you cement it as say this counter
rotation by RNG both side double TV
Antonio determine big record of the
flash
two three that Chase forward big once
everything and Alexi rather and though
it's gonna be have traded down to the
turret Baker pulled him into the damage
on but who is he waiting the wings
though the silences on will they
reengagement was look for the play and
he puts them into the turret the damage
every governor crossroads Baker the back
towards the jungle is blank
losing the health permit and Eliza
deadly venom not going to be quite
enough damage nine five simple with the
instant teleport down that ways the
engage cool Jerry J kit look for the
flat for get quickness into the hero's
engine look at the clock out the
mechanics job nine five seven of the
slicing maelstrom is doing what he can
to turn around
it's too little it's too late but he's
down girl gets another ruler got the
first and death will get - killed by
Cubase nah get something happened it's
all depends if W wants to sit the bet
Bishop
but we'll be picked up by Rulon satiate
Marines could not take his single tower
it started it much the same way look at
this moon is in trouble he's already
used that flax remember this Sun round
no binding connects peanut he's gonna
collect very killed but by seven kills
four and a half minutes go for it
I mean the kills are getting traded
pretty evenly but the problem is look at
how much gold is going to be funneled
into this which they already do the
church work buddy peanuts gun and not
that he's on a rampage but for five
minutes on the clock slaves run out of
in we went for the smite queue here now
slay looking for the passive auto Oh
Archie is actually getting hard for not
flashing that initial engage peanut he's
getting sucked in here already what your
next do now look guys the plays in that
last section we're sick of course but
let's be honest we're cherry-picking for
this video and the current timeline is
not the best if you're a Korean League
of Legends fan so let's take it back
even further to 2015-2016 when SKT reign
supreme
they're down in the bottom Lane Chow
who's left alone he hops over the
minions side steps a deadly flourish mlx
cheese looking for the kill
sonic wave connects resonating strike do
quite just survive
[Applause]
there and Buffington's come in now to
the midlane a nice son of the say oh
she's got to get away from the fakir to
reengage what's the bull and he's gonna
deliver Chenin to the back lines can
they do it up damage though his peanut
in a tick down with the hemo flakes
stayin alive though no stun on the prey
and the reengaged still pray Watson we
have gonna find one dives in for a
second and he does will not take any
damage that's the triple for him
Kuro takes one of the other ones and
down Smurf will fall scumbag curls
steals it away just going to back off
simmer all pop are they gonna go oh who
did n't quite get to bang me my wolf
comes back of the head both Paul Grice
granny Kaiser comes out and reignover
for any of the back lines of dingy where
the big absolute zero Maurin is huge
literally because that wild growth
weenie manages to catch Baker with his
ultimate fat Baker back you a fanatic in
big troubles gopher baby ready make it a
triple kill
created to the maximum size turn on
gorilla and they always have the
aggressive words that let them make
plays like this kick is in the chase
through as well makeup gonna smog gonna
lay in the route to peanut but there's
just not enough damage to deal you love
really once in though can he get the
attacks I'm gonna go for the from peanut
still alive somehow but Scouts there
with a vengeance now on to curl they go
the roots gonna land it'll couple more
shots should do it but he's taking up
freeways this thought he might kill a
flare-up but no now he's in the danger
zone this could be enough and now it's
still going to be the one picked up
nicely played by Kerr to get away damage
across on this one Goro going to lose
his life as well and that is the ace for
one beautifully played by Rox Tigers
they have double mountain breaks it
speaks to their strengths of being able
to burst out the bear and they're hoping
to get wall to pull out through
: wish you've already been used a trick
is running away expected sport out
he needs me
[Applause]
to taste the best timing
was insane
that is how to use your fit get gold
leave a group up they dare the rocks
Tigers to come towards it and they peel
completely as a unit now it soft peanut
to try Steelers ultimate is up in about
ten seconds yeah I think he's gonna look
for the strike to run flash away from if
he few really cuts amounts for that
Lauren he's gonna find Santa run right
before the dragon pit looks like he's
gonna try to get over the wall now I
gotta work though Oh chilling smite sent
torn in a lot of trouble you're less out
of the lantern
feint move from sneaky down to the
bottom lay and look at the baby glasses
a Duke honestly doesn't want to
Washington fog of war and he's got the
damage Baker gets the shutdown well
played by SKT jungle this started out
how smoothy gonna run out of unbreakable
well he will be broken picked up blank
getting his third kill the game an
immaculate engaged time security area
what was he can't is not as easy as I'm
saying here where are you in the walk
into a skate instead well there's the
shuffle fakers got Empress to [ __ ]
the norm is luckily a channel just yet
pink is going to be the next focus Jana
was able to kill faker now Laura's
looking for real life just find it
challenges down Maria's gonna stay alive
ain't care too white
bang left uncontested on the back line
he continues to Auto Attack wool for the
- bad luck of Yarmouth get in the fight
man no one attacks down yet the
boomerang goes I'm not gonna fly a slow
Shh - Jericho
we faded as KT by H 2k sorry right there
he jumps in and when real thinks I can
one-shot this guy he blocks the damage
now you guys don't need me to tell you
those were some of the best place we've
ever seen on the summer is rift but
getting your DeLorean because we're
going back even further to a time when
Kalia had to play catch-up to the rest
of the world and spoiler alert it did
not take them long to start dunking on
the rest of the regions they went for
the three tries to escape it but that
was a very quickly double Guilford on a
set up nicely
get the cat socks Wars oMG put backs
away meanwhile in the top lane we have
again flame and Darien pretty much going
hence ahead just bashing themselves
against each other from now on but the
thing is he's got a nice slowly of life
we'll see if he can actually stay on -
Darien and those reckless swedes coming
in as he gets love that attacks be
coming up there is right right puffs as
well he's going to get healthier from
Diamond fronts but can be some impacts
comes down Darien is still managing to
walk away
the reckless sweet coming out that is a
lunar will team to flame as well and
guess what they are turning this one
around Ivan the one that we trouble here
comes an alias man from across the other
side and diamond will fall in the anthem
of boy so loosely ridiculous that farm
going on vegetable put some pressure
down but faker actually turns out a lot
of damage
Reginald is aggressive with ultimate Oh
gets it down gently has been popular see
how daddy rolls with this one teleport
is available for Alex the question is
what time does he come in our equation
is now we do see his field from Danny
that has been enough with the questions
at what cost
the first victim of the fighting is
dahlias now kenja full HP boydle still
alive in the background we do see Danny
securing a kill unto time in fronts
genga still untouched
Danny's jumped back in this is a triple
kill now Ganges the Ross Logan you're
doing the best you can to pick up kills
account in surprise available this is in
almost ace for ozone right item honesty
for a shower just in the wrong moment
you see Johnny now mission house is in
that where you publish is the spread out
as a No
come on bulletin that his career
absolutely demolishing China in their
own base is that Walton in a little late
to the party on this one he's fight it
for dandy no Steele's coming in a good
right of damage coming in from amazed
welcome people locking down intervention
comes out night sleeve from looper is it
enough though wildturtle takes down Mata
that's a double kill coming in for him
they start to clean up this fight but
now they're all spread out the wrong
positions not in her answer coming in
from bjergsen but they have lost four
members and knees trying to run by
so great tempest / [ __ ] actually
doesn't walk down Pearson's just a range
move still try to find
first laps and pressure really that has
happened to the entire game Supercross
continuing the pressure those shy
Hopkins often once again rnase down
there but I don't know if he's gonna be
able to do anything until the towers I
mean she's not about real full tower
hits this time it should be enough that
managed to keep him stood there for
quite a while but you can see rapid
stock beautiful water girls heavy now
split and Carrie's gonna be kill again
he might try for any gauge here in March
I got for the guys there's gonna be
ultimate coming out for movement is it
enough toys and surely you'll get off
these down to an act right now about ten
flowers getting died from the damage
really coming from the groom bow at the
back just bleeding out at least running
at all
Oh
[Applause]
I couldn't see your boss get a better
turn around than that make me in trouble
you see the job the waters gonna move
inside it ship will it be enough to get
us water yeah we'll pick up the kill but
will it be the dense one because look at
the top of the tower no coupon do
getting a little antsy on this one tries
to get it was IRA he made with himself
in the water no White's gets popped up
my struggle toward collate he's gobbling
he finished it the Granada circuit in
the days before his fight
[Applause]
they can do it they will win the best of
five well guys that's our best up for
this week now if you want to see more
content like this for example the best
of Korea getting dunked on well you know
what to do hit the subscribe button hit
the like button and don't forget to
comment below and I'll see you next week
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]